okay so the ending of the batman has
some major things going on with it we
see the introduction of a classic
character through barry keown get the
destruction of gotham and also watch as
selena kyle heads off to bloodhaven with
matt reeves stating he'd love to create
a trilogy i thought we'd take a look at
where we leave things off to theorize
what could be coming next full spoilers
ahead so if you haven't had a chance to
check it out then i highly recommend
that you check out now riddle me this
who loves a thumbs drive with a with a
thumbs up
this guy we'll just we'll skip the crap
jokes for now and get into it but cheers
for checking out the video now the
ending of the movie has the riddler
meeting a mysterious arkham inmate
played by barry keown there's been a lot
of evidence to say that this is actually
the joker including comments made by
matt reeves and barry's brother who got
drunk a couple of months ago and posted
about it on facebook quite funny and the
riddler and the joker have somewhat of a
tenuous friendship in the comics and
though they've worked together in the
past i think going forward they'll
actually become enemies the graphic
novel the war of jokes and riddles would
definitely provide a basis for this in
case you don't know this is a year 2
story that was set after the riddler had
turned gotham into a wasteland in the
events of dark city the riddler actually
flooded gotham and this is pretty much
what we see happen at the end of the
movie a shout out to grace randolph for
also pointing out that we get the line
he's spoken for at the end which is
something that selena also gives lip
service to in the film dark city was a
new 52 story whereas the war of jokes
and riddles was a rebirth one but there
were several nodes to the former even
though they may not strictly be in the
same continuity that being said though
the time frame is right to create
something like this and i think they'll
likely combine elements of the two now
in the long halloween after the death of
falcone happened the entire landscape of
crime in the city changed whereas
batmania won and the air two stories
dealt primarily with the mob coal mine's
death massively altered things and we've
very much got the rise of the
supervillain the power vacuum that is
now being created is the perfect point
to have a wall like this that has the
super villains all fighting for
dominance in the middle of gotham
however i think the biggest influences
will be the book's cataclysm road to no
man's land and no man's land itself the
first of these had an earthquake hit
gotham that completely leveled the city
and it destroyed several properties and
lives this led into road to no man's
land and no man's land which was very
much about the city falling apart this
was somewhat touched upon in the dark
knight rises and we watched as the
citizens attempted to make a life for
themselves whilst the criminals fought
for control no man's land pulled in
several supervillains who chose their
sides and it was very much a civil war
between the criminals of the most
notorious comic book city they ended up
creating their own territories amongst
the landscape and going ahead this would
be the perfect way for reeves to
introduce villains from batman's rich
rogues gallery this could include bane
who was foreshadowed when batman
injected himself with a green substance
at the end of the movie this sent him
into an uncontrollable rage in which he
almost killed someone and therefore i
think he'll cast it to the side however
bane might not see the bad side of it as
he's happy to kill people and thus he
could end up taking it and using it as a
steroid like how he does in the source
material this would introduce him in a
big bad way and i'd love to see dave
batista playing him if he gets cast he
could help to carve up the city and a
similar situation happened in the war of
jokes and riddles as we saw from the
batman reeves likes to pick and choose
certain elements from graphic novels
that span the dark knight's rich history
and there are some classics there with
all the aspects of the finale playing
out the way that they do i think that
they might end up mixing the two and
we'll get a combination of dark city war
of jokes and riddles and also no man's
land now an interesting aspect of the
movie is that the bruce wayne persona is
completely absent and even when he
appears at events he seems completely
checked out like you probably are
because my voice is so boring but listen
up your chump put your phone down here
because there's a major way that this
could factor into the future of the
franchise during no man's land bruce
actually traveled out to a hearing in
order to try and argue that gotham was
worthy of aid bruce is berated in the
movie for not really being a
philanthropist by bella real and
potentially the two could end up going
to the government to beg for help this
would mean that bruce would need to
develop his persona and it would show
him that being a wayne can do things
that being batman can't that was a big
point of contention in the film between
bruce and alfred and if we look at the
book zero year on earth one the british
butler had to convince him to lean into
being bruce because it also had its
benefits batman is a guy in a cape and
he can't exactly help with things like
flooding so i believe bruce developing
this will be an important moment for the
character
now i just want to give a huge shout out
to today's sponsor extra who've made it
so you'll never need your bad credit
card again i've never really had a
credit card and because of this i just
don't really have that much of a credit
score i mean i don't really like the
idea of being in debt and then having to
pay that back and i know a couple of
people that have gotten to a lot of
trouble just for overspending so i've
always kind of avoided them but it did
cause some issues when me and my wife
tried to get a mortgage however what
extra does is that it allows you to
build a credit score with a debit card
extra is a debit card that's linked to
your account and because of this you
can't overspend either this also means
there's no interest against you building
away in the background and you don't
need to have a credit score to get the
card either what makes extra better than
the other debit cards is that you also
get up to one percent back in reward
points on the extra store so you can get
bonuses just by paying your bills and
other day-to-day expenses life can come
at you fast and you never know when
you're gonna get hit with builds that
will severely affect your credit score
for the rest of your life because of
this extra israel game-changer that can
start you off on the right path as i
mentioned earlier i only use my debit
card so this has really helped me as i
can build credit get rewards not
overspend and completely miss all the
hassle that comes with a credit card if
you're in the same boat as me and this
sounds like something that's going to
massively help you out then you can
check out my link in the description
below extra have also put together a
great list of frequently asked questions
gone over the cod in way more detail and
outlined why this is definitely worth
getting if this is something you're
interested in then click the link in the
description to get some help from extra
never leave the cave without it cheers
now alongside the joker and riddler we
have several other super villains that
could be popping up due to falcone's
death there's going to be a big seize
for power and we know that the penguin
will be vying for this matt reeves has
stated that the hbo max show starring
him is closer to production than the
gcpd one and i would love to see the
series chronicle his time with moroni
through the use of flashbacks on the
flip side of this we could also watch as
he expands his club and drug empire as
the people of gotham are probably gonna
need something to take their minds off
of all the emotions flooding in now
reeves is also stated that he wants mr
freeze in the franchise at some point
matt frieves
[ __ ] sake has a lot of things to pick
from and i believe that the heart of ice
episode will be what he pulls from the
most this emmy award-winning entry of
the batman animated series humanized the
villain i think the landscape of gotham
is now the perfect place to have him
show up gotham is completely flooded and
if elements of this were to be frozen it
could turn the entire city into a giant
ice rink now freeze was given the cold
shoulder after batman and robin but i
think the arkham games somewhat revised
stylized his public perception and
showed general audiences that he's
naughty but ice cool party now what's at
the center of the character is the need
to save his wife nora and they may
reveal that she was badly injured during
the flooding possibly even having
drowned breeze could have cryogenically
frozen her and be looking for a way to
change the water within her lungs which
is why he's experimenting with freezing
terrible terrible plot idea from me
there that oh it wouldn't really fit
this world but i think you know they
could do things along those lines and
they get paid more than me to come up
with better ideas so bloody come up with
them now freeze popping up could be
teased in the upcoming gcpd series and
it would be the perfect way to break the
ice
always winterize
your pants this will likely be based
upon the phenomenal graphic novel series
gotham central which had a mr
freeze-centric story in it the police
could end up attempting to stop him and
then after they lose we could watch as
batman realizes he's a much bigger
threat and that he'll need to use his
license to chill to go kick his ice
now the next part of the video is where
i want to discuss what i think matt
reeves joker will be like the director
is clearly pulling major aspects from
the new 52 run and in that scott snyder
introduced a version that ended up
cutting his face off and wearing it as a
mask the joker in this universe looks
severely scarred and burned and he could
end up disfiguring himself to me it's
the most terrifying version of the clown
prince of crime and i can see it fitting
this universe even though them two
warner brothers do want to keep it pg-13
now in that run the joker was very much
painted out as being in love with batman
as an idea he saw himself as a jester to
the king of gotham and ended up
capturing all his allies in the death of
the family the hull run by scott snyder
is absolutely astounding and there's
some amazing joker stories in there such
as one called endgame which i definitely
recommend you pick up now as for
catwoman i think she will probably be
getting her own show and this would make
for the perfect thing to have on hbo max
reeves has said the movie is based
heavily on the long halloween and in
that catwoman actually leaves at one
point in order to go to europe in the
book when in rome we followed her
adventures and i think bloodhaven could
be a similar sort of situation she could
really make a name for herself become
the catwoman and then come back for a
sequel
who's swing
sorry
now speaking of the long halloween its
sequel dark victory introduced robin and
there was actually a couple of
candidates in the movie that i think
would make for a great one is of course
the mayor's son and early on there's a
lot of focus on him at the start of the
movie we see him in a ninja outfit
training with a sword and he of course
has the qualifications of having a dead
parent to make him a robin like bruce
he's been through a lot of pain and
trauma at a young age and in the same
way that bruce watched his parents die
in front of him we learned that the boy
was the one who discovered his dad he
really needs a father figure in his life
and i think it would really balance
bruce out if you also got a surrogate
son now going beyond this there was also
the kid at the train station he had half
a mask symbolically showing he was half
into this lifestyle and he could end up
becoming a jason todd type character who
also started off as somewhat of a
criminal in the comics jayton was
introduced as basically a dick racing
clone but this was later retconned to
distinguish him from dick he stole the
tyres off the batmobile and batman ended
up taking him under his wing this could
also set up a red hood story which so
far hasn't been touched upon in a batman
film you know that the joker is coming
and therefore he could kill this version
of robin and that would just set up a
massive overarching thing that i think
would be really fun in a live action
movie i think that this kid at the train
station would be the perfect character
to do that with as there's a lot of
avenues for the future that they could
go with him and there was also a lot of
focus given to his introduction the hell
are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance reeves might have been
sowing the seeds for a robin under our
very eyes and i'd love to see one of
them become the boy wonder at some point
in the future there's so many ways i can
take things and this franchise has got
me really excited for what's in store
[Music]
please do not lie
what is the price
[Music]
now i know every month that i run a
competition and i'm so sorry i've just
been swept off my feet recently with the
kids and trying to balance youtube so i
haven't had a chance to pick out the
prizes for this month however i do have
the winners of the last competition on
screen right now if that's you then hit
me up on twitter heavyspoilers and if
you want to be entered into the next
competition which we don't know what the
prize is yet so great great thing to get
entered into then just comment below and
yeah we'll pick one of them at random at
the end of the month in between now and
then i'd also love to hear your thoughts
on the film so comment below and let me
know on screen right now we have our
full movie breakdown which talks about
the ending the easter eggs and
everything going on in the film without
the way thank you for clicking this i've
been paul you've been the best and i'll
see you next time robin you're gonna be
my robin take care peace